welcome to the program I'm joining you
once again today from very very hot and
dry Las Vegas Nevada on the bonus show
today I will talk a little bit about
what's been going on here at the
conference and tell a few stories been
seeing a lot of progressive media people
but a lot of views to get right into and
I want to start with the what seems to
be really an escalating serious
situation yesterday I told you that
President Trump took to Twitter and
started threatening Syria and Russia in
a way that we couldn't really determine
the credibility of nor really get a
sense of whether Trump understood the
geopolitical forces at play and
certainly my sort of default was he
probably can't understand it and this
relates to allegations of attacks by
Syrian leader Bashar al-assad on his own
people this relates to how Syria and
Russia have been in cahoots to differing
degrees but what we could tell from
yesterday was that Trump was certainly
doing the exact opposite of what he said
presidents should do in the sense of
saying in advance what military action
might be taken right whether or not we
take Trump's so-called threat seriously
from from yesterday that we talked about
whether we believe that the tweets were
political posturing or sort of a
bonafide military threat effectively
what we know is that he was stating in
pretty specific terms what the u.s. his
involvement would be in what would
trigger it just as a reminder Trump's
tweet yesterday said this was one of
three tweets that we showed you
yesterday Russia vows to shoot down any
and all missiles fired at Syria
get ready Russia because they will be
coming nice and new and smart you
shouldn't be partners with a gas killing
animal who kills his people and enjoys
it and Trump has correctly been getting
slammed since he would previously
criticize Obama or Hillary and others
for supposedly telegraphing what they
would do militarily Trump's big thing
throughout the entire campaign and even
before he was running for president
during Barack Obama's presidency was we
shouldn't ever give a timeline we
shouldn't ever say what we're going to
do because that's information that the
enemy or whoever might be able to use
against the United States
so Trump was rightly slammed for doing
the exact same thing he criticized
others of doing and he's now defending
himself obviously on Twitter which is
sort of his primary means of defense
increasingly not taking actual questions
from reporters and a sort of live
in-person format instead to sending out
these weirdly punctuated tweets he tried
to defend himself from the criticism by
saying never said when an attack on
Syria would take place could be very
soon or not so soon at all in any event
the United States under my
administration has done a great job of
ridding the region of Isis where is our
thank you America now I get what he's
doing Trump is trying to make the plan
seem unknown and not predictable because
he previously said that's how our
military should operate
he criticized others when they would say
here's what I would do here's what I
would like to do here's what we might
want to consider doing and he was
slumped lamb because he was doing the
same thing so Trump saying we might
attack soon or not so soon at all which
is I guess being interpreted as maybe
not at all period he's trying to make it
seem like he's not really staying what
the plan is he's not really doing that
exact same thing which he criticized
others for doing we aren't saying what
it is we are going to do but as soon as
Trump changes his position from here's
what we will do if Syria Russia does x2
we might do this soon or we might not do
it at all then it's not actually
anything right obviously Trump could
strike a country soon not soon or not at
all he doesn't have to say that in order
for those to be the sort of options and
even though Trump kind of appears to be
adding vagueness to the timing element
of it he's really removing all meaning
and value that he originally
communicated with the tweets that we
talked about yesterday but in the midst
of this it actually does seem like we're
moving in the direction of military
action and I've been talking about this
actually here at the conference a lot of
progressive media people last night we
were talking about what we think is
going to happen in Syria and there's
every indication that this is moving in
the direction of military action we now
have you know there's a there's often
this question with Syria of did they
really attack their own people and did
they really use chemical weapons France
is now saying the French president is
now saying they have proof that Syria
used chemical weapons in Syria over the
weekend we have Britain's cabinet
meeting to talk about a potential joint
operation with the United States
military we've learned of Brit British
submarines that are moving within range
of Syria and we've also heard a
declaration from Germany from the German
Chancellor Angela Merkel that they are
not going to be part of a coordinated
action against Syria but that they are
supportive of sending a message that
chemical weapons simply cannot be used
so these are you know I don't know if I
want to call them the the beating of the
drums of war but certainly we are seeing
more and more declarations and actions
that suggest that's the direction we're
going in and on the other side it seems
as though Syria is also taking this
seriously moving some military aircraft
to a Russian base in Syria protecting
some weapon systems so if you look just
at those signatures it appears that this
is the direction things are moving in
will that does that mean anything
definitive certainly not and there's of
course a debate to be had over military
action in Syria right do we believe or
not believe that Bashar al-assad has
used chemical weapons do we believe or
not Mali believe that military action by
the US or a coalition would be justified
or not and this relates to broader
questions about the philosophy
geopolitically of the United States is
the world policeman a pre-emptive or
proactive Wars when the United States is
not directly threatened that there's all
those philosophical debates to be had
but what's most stunning and notable
here in the world of diplomacy which is
really what's been sort of turned on its
head by the current administration is
that Trump is totally erratic and
ignorant as far as what's taking place
there because remember ten days ago
eight 12 days ago something like that
Trump was saying I'm gonna pull all US
troops from Syria and very very soon and
then his military advisors got to him
and said well hold on a second that that
that's not a good idea
that's drastic let's not do that right
now that idea appears to have completely
evaporated and now we have a new one
which is possible military action up to
and including a military coalition with
allies so aside from analyzing the
geopolitical implications of each plan
there are like a there's a meta
geopolitical consequence here which is
that when Trump does this stuff no one
knows what on earth the United States is
about to do and trumpets might see this
and say hey that's good it's good that
other countries don't know what it is
Trump is going to do because that's how
we keep them on their toes that's sort
of like saying having a driver that you
can't predict whether they will stay in
their lane or decide to drive in the
lane of oncoming traffic is good because
it keeps everybody on their toes it's
dangerously erratic it prevents
diplomacy and it also prevents the
United States from actually moving
forward diplomatically in our
relationships with other countries
because Trump says one thing on Twitter
and then his quote generals say yeah
we're not doing that and then he says
another thing on Twitter days later
that's the exact opposite if you ask me
what I actually think will happen in
Syria I don't know if I had to bet I
would bet on some military action but
again it might be that type of thing
where the United States bombs an empty
air airfield after everybody's been
warned and then Trump calls it some kind
of major coup of military display and
power I don't know but it's it's not
looking stable and it's not looking good
and more than likely by the time we get
back from our break I'll
we'll have changed in terms of what
happened in Syria today's episode is
made possible in part by zipper ZPE our
banks and other financial institutions
are pretty conservative when it comes to
approving loans and the major problem
with this is not that they're being
cautious but that immigrants and
students and other disadvantaged groups
often don't have the requisite credit or
income to be approved zipper's goal is
to use smart contract technology and
their new cryptocurrency to provide a
revolutionary method of funding
transactions between borrowers and
lenders worldwide which would allow
people with no or little credit to
borrow currency through alternative
forms of verifying creditworthiness on
Zippers blockchain Zippers initial coin
offering for their new cryptocurrency
starts April 16th if you're watching on
youtube look in the description for a
link to their website and links to
information about their airdrop and
bounty programs this is not financial
advice and everybody should do their own
research